started it as induction proof right the
reason why
is because even though the questions say
do it by induction um why not
right because induction is a method of
proof and as the question sort of set up
number one you already know what you're
trying to prove that's a requisite for
induction number two
you're dealing with integer values
induction doesn't have to deal with
integers but it usually does
right um and number three
when you're you don't just know this you
actually know all the intervening values
right so you can test things out
so that's why this question is sort of
induction shaped even if they don't say
you know prove it this way so i just
thought
i'd draw something out even though that
doesn't necessarily contribute to my
solution because it helps me wrap my
brain around what's happening
and then you can see i've just sort of
started out my first three steps right
so test it
um first of all value i just put is
three because if you have
anything less you don't really have a
polygon right um
then i assume now i have to prove this
is the fun part right now when you look
at this
how could you possibly work in your
assumption
into here that's that's the real that's
the question
right does anyone have any ideas how
would you go about doing it
this this thing here i could expand
um it would end up with something that i
would argue is no more complicated
or no more simple than what i'm going to
get in a second uh i'm gonna so i'm
gonna leave it factorized for now
i think it really depends on this thing
it has to come from there somehow
okay because if i'm gonna bring this
in right i don't have it on the right
hand side uh even if i did have it on
the right hand side what would it
achieve for me to bring it back in okay
so i think the key
is to really understand what happens
when you go from
i'm just calling capital b the number of
diagonals i've got right what happens
when you go from one
k to the next one k plus one well that's
why it's actually useful to have this
diagram okay or this set of diagrams
because you can see a pattern can't you
t pattern as you go from one to the next
what's changing in the number of
diagonals well it's getting more but for
how much
as you add in um one
vertex vertices as you add in a corner
right you go from zero to two right
so plus two diagonals okay
as you move over from four to five you
add how many diagonals
three right now by the way because the
pattern is starting to
come out why is it that this uh number
that we add on
is so um methodical right well two
reasons number one
um and you can sort of see it because
i've got enough diagrams here right
number one
you've got more uh vertices to draw out
diagonals to other
places right because if you think about
it this way
i started here and i drew one and then i
drew another one so i drew it twice
right from two starting points and then
i was finished there were no more
diagonals i could draw
when you go for this one you're adding
in an extra point that can go to more
places right so you've got more starting
points
but secondly can you see the other thing
that's growing as you go from here to
here to here
each corner right not only are there
more corners but each corner sends out
more diagonals
right see here i've got one diagonal per
corner
there's just one coming out then you've
got two every corner has two diagonals
and then here um you've got three right
so that's why it's growing in this
very sensible way okay so from here to
here
plus four now what kind of series is
this
now this this this series in here that's
arithmetic right
um common difference of one but the
actual series i'm interested in
d is not arithmetic is it
like it's just it's just a series it's
not art it's not geometric it's just
that okay so if i'm gonna try and break
apart that series how would i do it i
can't use my normal
rules or formula for aps or for gps so
what do i do
well i'm going to say here's my left
hand side okay
that the k plus one term
whatever it is whatever rules it follows
right it's going to be
the previous uh well the previous k
terms right
that one plus whatever the next one is
normally uh that okay does that make
sense
so for instance if i was looking for the
um 100th term
it would be the first 99 terms sorry the
first 100 terms it'd be the first 99
plus the 100 right so that's my k that's
my k plus one
right now this is useful because i'm
trying to work in my assumption
right so so that's that's good okay i've
got my
d k there but
in solving one problem bringing it in
i've introduced another one
what is this thing what is k plus one
how do i go about finding it
remember it's monday p are a gp right so
we can't use our
our ready-made rules for those what else
can i do
observe the pattern exactly right right
so i want to watch what's happening here
okay and you can make some educated
guesses
i'm going to go straight for the algebra
okay because not only can i observe the
pattern i already have
um an algebraic expression for the
pattern okay so i'm going to say if i
want to work out
t of k plus 1 i'll put this off on the
side okay t
of k plus 1 okay if i want to work out
say the
100th term a way of thinking about that
is well
if you take the first 100 terms
okay and then you subtract all the ones
except for the one you're interested in
right i think that's wrong
so i should have done this i think
that's what i wanted okay can you see
what i'm doing here okay
i'm taking the sum of every term up onto
this one and then i'm taking away all
the previous ones all the ones i don't
want
right so what does this land on what
does it look like well i know what all
of these pieces are
because i define them that way right
sorry this is a d
i keep on thinking of um
okay is that a little that makes a
little more sense okay so d of k plus
one
is going to be k plus one k
minus two on two yep
and i know what this is already that's
okay
okay minus three okay oh you go
what does it work out to you tell me
two k minus two because i've got here
what i got
um k squared minus two k
plus k minus two minus
k squared minus three k yeah
all on two that's just one fraction yes
okay so i've got k squared minus k
so this k squared will cancel with this
k squared
yeah i've got minus k here
plus 3 k so 2 k minus
2 yeah and that's actually all over
two so fast so k
minus one okay now does that make sense
of course it makes sense because k minus
one is exactly what we're adding as
we're going from term to term right
two and then three and then four okay
you see how it's growing in the same way
all right now i can actually put this
into place
so um here what have i got
okay k minus three
right does it fit
we don't want to go we don't want to go
this is going to be two
on two yes so i've got k
squared minus three k plus
two k minus two hold over
k squared minus k minus two
does it check out i actually
i should have left myself a line but
that's going to end up here the
factorized bit that i was after
right that's equal to uh
i can just fit it
i don't know what i was after okay now
yeah are you allowed to make that
assumption of the k-plus one because
that's what your
proof yeah this part here okay so
two things uh i i am assuming what d of
d of k is that's my that's my inductive
step
right so i really should have said by
assumption here
because if
this one yeah okay
yes but no because i'm not uh i'm not
assuming this is true
right i'm actually working it out based
on what kind of site i should have said
um as d
is a what's the word i'm looking for
is a progression that's all i want
right because that's the definition of
something which is progressing from term
to time
right so that's why it's not it's not as
circular as it looks
i think the hard part was here
that one the actual step we're talking
about okay because it's not intuitive
that like you you'd go in that direction
um and how else do you break apart this
guy
that's the hard part okay uh now you
guys got lucky there were no
geometry uh induction questions
for now when your trial rolls around um
they'll make another appearance because
in your hsc
they'll make another appearance actually
if you go when we get to the time when
we get to look at real hsc exams you'll
see lots of geometry industrial
questions in there
um because geometry induction questions
are hard so that's why they make you do
it
okay so anyway